guys here it is gamespot's III flippin
alright looks a little bigger than last
year's can I bring my fancy lobby chair
can't really talk about video games on
the internet without my fancy lobby
chair wait who's this area over here for
oh that's where the kind of funny guys
are gonna be sitting oh nice wait what
dude they're gonna eat all of our food
yeah I mean they are right now
you have any wings this June watch the
guys from kind of funny team up with
gamespot for the best III coverage of
all time watch the game spot stage for
demos of all the latest titles announced
at e3 2015 and watched the kind of funny
stage to watch the guys hang out with
the biggest names on the internet to
talk about everything happening at the
show that's two shows two streams
broadcast directly from the e3 show
floor into your eyeballs this coming
June check it out LA Convention Center
my right things are happening I hope
they announce full at 40 they don't man
[ __ ] them yeah oh my god Greg Miller hey
Danny they do so i'm good how are you
Colin Moriarty good to see you thank you
very much back no worries uh yeah you
wanna hang out in most yellow confetti
let's 33 together they didn't see how
many people we can shove into the booth
that's what I really want to see how
many we have two stages how can we out
loud each other can I be so loud on our
stage that I ruined your stream yep oh
yeah probably yeah great do I not a
couple of those faceoffs last year and
yeah i'm gonna kick it up and down so
yeah you had Neil druckmann will be over
there trying to tell you something all
right wow you're great you're gonna have
Cisco on your stay right right now we
have a soft commit from cisco that is
riley and down on the guy you did a
thong song that is not a joke like I we
basically the woman when you guys came
to us and said do you want to run second
stage and do whatever you want on it we
are oh great this is a chance for us to
hang out with all our dumb la friends
yeah so I was like we say the video game
in the zone oh no wait you didn't say
that so you didn't say that when you you
win a game of the dump truck full of
money that was important caveat cisco
devon Sawa we're getting everybody in
there everybody you expect not to expect
all the hot current celebrity okay
so in Devon solid well video game people
in was very exciting a lot of people
we're talking a lot of people that
descends yeah great yeah it's gonna be
very very funny now it's out in the air
so we can talk that we even talked about
it yeah so we're gonna have the game
spot stage in our usual spot in the the
Ceph hole in the LA Convention Center
you guys going to be right beside us
yeah Your Honor the stage as well what
do you guys gonna be doing because
people kind of know what we do yeah demo
games like all the games that are
intensity three games that we already
know about that are going to be playable
for the first gem there we're going to
be playing on our stage so what are you
guys going to be doing what did we
decided to do because this is a like a
new III like experience for you guys all
right yeah you figure for eight years
basically we've done what you're doing
yeah it's so now to be out there the way
we do is we're going to keep doing what
we already do over on kind of funny
right which of course youtube.com slash
kind of funny kinda funny games and all
edges um the the thing about their right
is that we interpret the news with our
audience and what you know I means we're
bringing on our friends from the
industry developers will be coming on
with us but they'll be coming on more to
talk about what's happening are they
excited by VR what's happening here not
so much to talk about their game
specifically not to show you a demo but
to talk about what's the best thing
they've seen so far if they haven't seen
anything we're giving them passes and
sending them out to go see games and
come back and report on what they think
of it such like that you just gonna have
random celebrity people be your
journalist exactly yes go out and so
it's about time they did something for
us you know what I mean that's a good
for ya get devon Sawa to go play black
ops 3 exam back he's actually will
sooner see someone I was wondering what
Devon solid think we're gonna find out
what does Casper think of blackout three
if i damned if kinda play doesn't figure
it out I think a couple thousand more
people now are demanding I think said
yeah we get up yeah the way we look at
it is that you know you guys do what you
do well and so like why try to compete
with that that's the whole manager kind
of funny anyways that we're not you know
when I we were at Jen we would break
news that break news and talk to sources
all that kinds of a now just like well
things happen like you guys are talking
about Konami and interpret it so yeah
but what's fun about this either II
thing is yeah we can have Harley from
Epic Meal Time for instance be like what
you think about alienation on PA well we
haven't played in rockville here's a
pass new google play it that's when i'm
back in 20 minutes 11 stop we're
bringing in Freddie Wong of course
Freddie's a good friend of ours and he
was before he got internet famous a
world champion guitar hero players oh
really I want him to go play all the
music games and come back
what he thinks it went stuff at that
world champion yeah oh my god you look
it up look at use this thing sometimes I
can you sure no I'm ass broke on it god
damn it yeah that is a total pro do you
do what do you do is it lights the side
of my face oh that's why i have it on
bright all the time okay like that like
it are you looking forward to this
year's e3 because one of the thing one
of the things this sort of happens when
you're covering the game so much is that
getting out there and actually trying to
like play games and actually trying to
get in the show floor and I talk people
to meet people do you think you'll have
sort of more of an ability to do that
this year now you're gonna just leave
but you're not gonna leave like making
Tim on the stage for a while you guys
keeps going dude we left Nick and Tim
alone on a stream once during GDC right
we did our stream every day for eight
hours we had all these developers come
in and stuff over on twitchtv kind of
funny games and we left them alone
literally once for literally five
minutes and they started talking about
pubes right away right so no they cannot
be left alone didn't eat very audience
to figure out what's going on Portillo
going uh no we're not gonna be able to
know he's gonna be that'd be really hard
to walk with you the video is a little
misleading then in that case I think we
better have yak portillo all right full
disclosure he's gonna get that was part
of the contract we didn't read with you
he's gonna get a hotel room yeah exactly
porcello's got the after-hours coverage
lockdown yeah of course yeah you can
come into the LA Zoo brandy snifters no
coat yeah I left it Burke what are you
guys looking forward to at e3 because
we're now getting into the stage we're
sort of all the games that are coming
out except for the witcher 3 are kind of
like yeah have happened now we'd broken
age today and it's gonna be that like
little couple of weeks where we're going
towards III where all the rumors start
to happen we already mentioned fallout 4
in the trailer but that's the one yeah
right that's the one that was a joke we
did at the end that thing as an ad lib
but I mean really like fall out what is
going on fall for clearance a lot a long
time in before in bethesda now their
conference will be announced and come
out this year and and I we thought about
is actually maybe even last time around
the show uh so I think that's the begin
what I get it so excited about is you
know cuz we have exhibitor badges were
able to get to the forum before during
the conference's is all the placards
with tape over them and all the the
curtains over yes for games that are
unannounced that's kind of the stuff
that's most exciting to me and hopefully
my number nines there so I can't play it
again dodging the forklifts and pallets
yeah people kind of looking at you like
shall we be here yeah not sure about
these people to be here but me
but what am I really and everyone's got
periscope yeah noticed some was just
gonna bundle their way into the Moscow
or as an Intel a convention center and
just be like someone dating someone
someone maybe me oh look it's that time
I pretended I was in fallout 4 on the
beach you do a lot of cool stuff and
yeah that was real fun that was like
five in the morning that's how I play on
for for for yeah and I think you're
there's been some like rumors about you
know if thez they're having like their
own conference but what else could they
possibly talk about yeah was it too yes
honored yes or dishonor and doom ok yep
but yeah it's got a bit gotta be for me
I think I think it's all just
everything's aligned to where they can
announce you know for for maybe this
year maybe the doom beta and all that
kind of stuff and that's coming out
maybe you know maybe something with a
prayer revival and obviously dishonored
so I'd there things to announce but uh
yeah I just feel like they have nothing
to gain by really announcing the game
and waiting a year they have nothing to
gain fought for will sell millions and
millions of copies if they stay today
it's ready and here it is it doesn't
matter so I think they know that I Todd
Howard knows that I think Pete Hines
knows that I think everyone over there
knows that and so they'll I think
they'll announce it'll come out probably
November and that Sunday night like III
does even started by the time we're
gonna do an event Bethesda still take
the women out of everyone's sales
immediately and it's not unprecedented
it would be okay maybe that time frame
will be unprecedented but they met
Skyrim at the VGX Azure vijay awards and
that was only in the december prior so
like they messed with in 12 works as
well as yeah and then they did a very
similar thing where we went you know
that at that time the next year like
april we went to utah to play the game
and then they kind of went quiet again
and then they just they released the
game so i knew people gonna buy the game
and i have every expectation to me Oh
awesome so it's it's um it's something
we've been waiting a long time for you
know immediately kind of immersive you
like working with the witcher 3 we're
imminently it's gonna be funny 3 i think
like last year people were kind of
hoping okay let's get the whole spread
of like new IP new new sort of
announcement games that really look like
they're like taking hold of the
current-gen consoles we kind of didn't
regain it what we wanted i feel like
this year is the year like some of those
consoles we're gonna have to get like
some nice big fancy my only fear right
is that instead of getting the nice big
games and things that
this is why you bought these next-gen
systems it's going to be hey here's
Morpheus and here's more VR stuff and
just be like please stop you know the
fount of you are I'm a fan enough but I
don't think it's gonna be super
successful yeah I don't want him to wait
burn a hole press conference talking
about it everybody stop calling I think
I mean I pulled the story before about
how when I first played oculus I played
eval curry this was several years ago at
e3 and I'd been to I was like this will
be like maybe my ninth or tenth III I
have no idea at this point but this was
the first time at e3 Rose like I want
can i play that again what can I do that
again and you know I wasn't a believer
until I played it and then I was like
wow this is going to be revolutionary
but I think there's a lot of commercial
realities that are gonna make it hard
for instance you need to have a
beautiful several thousand dollar rig to
be able to play oculus you need to have
a playstation 4 to play Morpheus when
the on when the processing is on board
one of these devices then I think that
it'll be more revolutionary when it
sticks into a television on its own like
I'm gonna be expensive it's me far-flung
and who knows when that's gonna happen
but since you need another piece of
hardware like that's that's gonna stop a
lot of people from enjoying yeah we're
looking at all the you know stuff right
now with morpheus right it's just like I
feel like we're repeating the sins of
the past with move yeah like you're
gonna introduce this in your alright
this is a you know the pie chart of
PlayStation 4 owners this is the number
of people who got it this is the number
of people who are gonna actually want to
play games every so often so developers
don't make games for it so it doesn't go
anywhere so it just fails yeah same kind
of experience that like you can watch
people doing it on TV but you're never
gonna get anything approaching the
experience of actually playing that like
you look you walk watch like a sick
fallout 4 demo you've got a great idea
of what's going on your a hype for that
like because they're seeing it but with
move and then with VR it doesn't show
well to someone watching a live stream
or watching a show so when how do you
sell to that PETA person it's the
Nintendo 3ds problematic and take it on
the road you know this pioneer using the
country or the thing happened with the
wii when they start shopping that around
but at least the thing with the wii was
it was a kind of a mass-market piece of
hardware where is this is all obvious
it's like a niche within in the other
already hey by this 400 our system and
then buy this piece of equip which is
probably gonna be worth like 250 years
and then x games for it yeah yeah all
the units your boys champions will be
phrase for my bad that i can i move on
cuz o thing for brat yeah what are used
we tried to believe
the UH the thing with the with weep with
women and move on it was that their
lease tactile and you can actually early
see the game I mean to your point like
you can actually show anyone even the
footage so I get earlier it's all this
is what it looks like in here is it you
can play it it's like we can even show
you what it looks like because it's not
possible so you need to actually put the
headset on and see we developer come
through on the show the game they've
been working on their super excited
about they're like it's VR and but your
audience I know can't look at that soul
displayed on mouse keyboard oh really is
like our cool this is cool then they put
the head so this is even cooler yeah but
it's like yeah how do you drive that
point home to somebody and then
developers as well when they're making
them are probably going to have be
making games that can at least fall back
to mess and keyboard because otherwise
they pigeonhole themselves it's going to
be funny 3 i'm looking forward to it
hopefully we'll have a bunch of
announcements on the software front
perhaps on the hardware phone as well
and if we don't we can all just hang
around we're never fun no matter what
come a good time yeah yeah we're gonna
with what you say yeah yeah zoosex
isaacs my girlfriend my girlfriend is
very excited for devon south Oh upper 20
girls oh the gauge girls really really
excited all the girls are excited for
Devon and all the guys excited cisco
we're gonna get down me and my buddy
Andy back in waterford we were like 13
years old we bought single copies of the
Tong song because it came with an mp4 of
the video oh wow which if you're a
thirteen-year-old boy is quite a good
you want that you wanted to see those
dumps like a truck I did I want to see
that power all the bosses turn up from
all the various cities in America your
bosses turn up from Washington and LA
these poor lady has been on a bus firm
or there is married energy they believe
anything they wanted a party in there
they ramped up there we go receita they
go there any weirdness if you're
probably ninety percent of yon might not
remember the thong song as well as we do
let's just go and he's excited to come
be three he's yet I'm his his lovely
finger glove better bring those two
finger glowing I would alright that's
enough of that then i guess i watch the
phone cell confirm if you want to watch
the tongs down you can go to what was
this kind of twitch TV for such kind of
funny funny that you guys just looping
all the time yeah exactly you're not
what we are here
I'm song and playing on to it